Ça y est ! Il est là-haut. Après 24 heures de voyage,
Thomas Pesquet est arrivé à bon port.
Il a rejoint l’ISS, la Station Spatiale Internationale
à 400 km au-dessus de nos têtes…
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi ça me fait rêver…
Thomas Pesquet est parti de Cap Canaveral et ça
ce n’est pas un hasard, c’est le meilleur endroit pour rejoindre l’espace.
Avec une fusée qui en plus ne ressemble pas aux autres.
Pourquoi partir de Cap Canaveral ?
Et quelle est la particularité de cette fusée ?
Je vous explique tout ça dans mon espace… au fond du jardin !
D’abord un petit flash back…
Previously in Chez Jamy
Depuis le début de l’aventure spatiale toutes les fusées décollent
suivant le même principe : celui d’action-réaction.
Principe énoncé par le Physicien Isaac Newton,et
que l‘on peut mettre en évidence avec un ballon de baudruche…
Thomas Pesquet se trouve ici : dans le module Colombus.
Il s’agit du laboratoire européen à l’intérieur duquel
il va travailler durant les prochains mois.
C’est un endroit que Thomas Pesquet connaît bien
puisqu’il a déjà effectué une mission à bord de l’ISS,
entre novembre 2016 et mai 2017 au cours de laquelle,
vous vous en souvenez sûrement, il a effectué 2 sorties extra véhiculaire…
Voici une maquette de la fusée Falcon 9, avec à son sommet
le vaisseau Crew dragon à bord duquel Thomas Pesquet
et 3 autres membres de l’équipage ont rejoint la station spatiale Internationale
qui gravite à 400 km au-dessus de nos têtes.
L’ensemble mesure presque 70 m de hauteur et pèse 550 tonnes.
Pour arracher l’engin du sol et lancer le vaisseau à près de 28 000 km/h,
la fusée est bien sur équipée de moteurs très puissants.
Il y en a 9. Mais les ingénieurs ne la font pas décoller de n’importe où…
Pour s’arracher du sol et gagner de la vitesse,
la Nasa fait décoller ses lanceurs depuis Cap Canaveral en Floride.
Cette base de lancement se trouve à un endroit très particulier
sur la planète… vous le voyez, assez proche de l’équateur…
C’est d’ailleurs aussi le cas de la base de lancement de ESA,
Agence Spatiale Européenne. Elle est installée à Kourou en Guyane,
c’est encore plus proche de l’équateur.
Cette position présente un énorme avantage.
En décollant d’ici, les fusées bénéficient
de ce que l’on appelle l’effet de fronde.
Vous connaissez !? Aller, suivez-moi dans le jardin je vais vous montrer.
Plus une fronde dessine de grands cercles,
plus elle a de l'inertie, plus elle a d'élan, plus le projectile va loin.
Chut... un peu de géométrie maintenant.
Vous le savez, la Terre tourne autour d’un axe
qui passe par les pôles. Un tour complet en 24 heures.
Cette rotation génère une force apparente
qu’on appelle la force centrifuge…
La force centrifuge vous connaissez !? C’est celle
qui vous pousse vers l’extérieur dans un virage…
cette force apparente liée à la rotation de la Terre est plus importante à l’équateur qu’ailleurs. Je m’explique
Toutes les 24 heures chaque point du globe exécute donc un cercle complet.
Quand la terre se déplace de 15 degrés sur son axe,
ce qui correspond à son déplacement pendant une heure.
N’importe quel point situé au niveau du 47ème parallèle,
au niveau de la France, parcours 1 100 km.
Maintenant, n’importe quel point situé au niveau de l’équateur, latitude 0,
parcourt pendant ce même laps de temps 1674 km.
Par conséquent, si pendant le même temps, une heure,
on parcourt une distance  plus grande au niveau de l’équateur
qu’au niveau du 47ème parallèle, eh bien c’est que,
au niveau de l’équateur on va plus vite…
1674 km/h ici, 1100 km/h là… cqfd…
L’effet de fronde, l’élan, est plus important ici que là…
D’où l’intérêt de décoller à proximité de l’équateur…
de cap Canaveral pour la NASA de Kourou pour l’ESA.
Cela dit, même en décollant de Floride,
le premier étage de la Falcon 9 a quand même besoin de neuf moteurs
pour fournir une poussée suffisante.
Ces moteurs fonctionnent avec un carburant spécial.
Dans le jargon, on parle d'ergols… Pour brûler dans les moteurs,
ce carburant a bien sûr besoin d’oxygène,
comme dans un moteur de voiture.
Sauf que dans le moteur d’une voiture,
l’oxygène est directement fourni par l’air extérieur.
En altitude, il n’y a pas assez d’air
dans l’atmosphère pour ça !
Et sans air...
ça ne brûle pas !
La fusée embarque donc sa propre réserve d’oxygène liquide,
dans des réservoirs situés au premier étage.
Le carburant, et l’oxygène liquide, sont injectés
dans la chambre de combustion du moteur,
où ils s’enflamment dès qu’ils entrent en contact l’un avec l’autre,
ce qui produit des gaz.
Alors je vous l’ai dit au début de la vidéo
la fusée Falcon 9 n’est pas comme les autres…
Environ 2 minutes 30 après le décollage,
le premier étage de la fusée Falcon 9 se détache.
Une fois la fusée sortie de l’atmosphère terrestre,
sa mission est terminée !
Le premier étage effectue alors une pirouette
et amorce sa descente vers la Terre.
Et tranquillement, il rentre au bercail.
C’est en effet la grande particularité des lanceurs de Space X.
Ils peuvent être réutilisés jusqu’à dix fois !
Mais revenons-en à notre fusée !
Quelques secondes après que le premier étage se soit détaché, c’est le moteur
situé au 2ème étage de la Falcon 9 qui se met en route
et prend le relais pour quelques minutes
avant de se détacher à son tour.
On est alors à plus de 200 kilomètres
au-dessus de la Terre !
200 km. À une queue d’étoile près…
Enfin une queue de vache, c’est... Bourges-Limoges !
À ce stade, il ne reste plus que la capsule Crew Dragon… C’est ce vaisseau spatial d’un peu plus de 8 mètres de hauteur
et de 3 mètres 70 de diamètre qui vient d’emmener Thomas Pesquet
et son équipage jusqu’à la station spatiale internationale,
avant de s’y arrimer.
Et c’est également à bord du Crew Dragon
que Thomas Pesquet rentrera sur Terre, dans quelques mois.
D’ici là… il va se passer beaucoup de choses là-haut
et on aura bien sur l’occasion d’en reparler.
En attendant, profitez bien des images que nous envoie Thomas Pesquet, rêvez, et à très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo.